at nine since I was four flowers gonna
be shooting in Star Wars film I would
have planned it all my life this film
these characters the story I grew up
with it's a whole world I've been
thinking about it for quite a long time
you can fill everyone in the career in
the cars kind of stops and just take
that in and you remember oh actually in
Star Wars it's like the world's greatest
toy set it's a bit like being that kid
again the star wars figures don't trip
was over here and this happens is
explosion it's been a lot of fun it's
the greatest job in the world
broke one takes place very close to
episode 4
the simplest way to explain it is that
text you see at the beginning of a new
hope
that is essentially a movie
they call it the Death Star terrible
weapon but there's a way to defeat him
Jen starting to put together a team she
wants to fight we all do how many doing
it it is an ensemble movie but at the
heart there's a strong woman the time to
fight is now every day they grow
stronger
all these characters are real heroes
that are willing to risk everything like
the police are and make 10 men feel like
a hundred through their journey we see
the formation of the Rebel Alliance and
stealing of the Death Star plans and you
are not willing to risk being left
behind
how's your chance to speak up that is a
bad idea hey they achieve what they
achieved because they achieve it
together this is wrote one
you